so when we think of the fan fan name um
somebody brings up with the idea like
what about the bell
then you know it's like kind of like a
hi belle everybody brings their bells
and like
make short noise and they're like bails
like ringling
did you hear that bts army this boy band
almost called their fan base the bells
but thank god that
um it has not you know it's
army's so much better yeah
bts appeared on tuesday's episode of the
tonight show starring jimmy fallon and
revealed lots of secrets
[Applause]
in addition to their original fan base
name jimin confessed that he nearly
adopted a different stage name
hi i'm baby jake
another fun fact v didn't actually
intend to try out for bts
v is it true that you never actually
intended on auditioning for bts you just
went to the audition
to support your friend swag true
yes what happened to your friend
[Laughter]
suga also revealed the first cd he ever
bought was by rapper eminem
[Music]
um
but this one has to be the most bizarre
secret ever
v sleeps with his eye eyes open
[Applause]
go oh yeah
that's it
all jokes aside bts opened up about
their first grammy nomination
last year it's really an honor you know
it's one of the biggest honor as an
artist
for of course for all of the all for the
world
i'm so happy so crazy and so thankful
for all the fans all over the world
that's it
i think this is the reason why you
should just speak out your ambitions you
know
it'll come true maybe maybe spoken into
existence
the boy band also talked about their
latest single permission to dance
[Music]
and they couldn't help but gush over ed
sheeran who co-wrote the track
ptd is a song that will get everybody's
heart pumping and dance again and you
know
this is a actually gift of ed sheeran of
course one of her friends
mad respect big love to add we can't
believe that we
haven't met him yet and you know this is
a second project with him
and when et spoke to bts in may the guys
gushed over the success
they've seen of course with the help of
their army it makes us
obviously feel really good it means that
a lot of people are listening to our
music and it wants us to keep working
harder so they can give back
a lot of this love that we're receiving
we are looking forward to touring as
much as our fans are looking forward to
it
so when things do improve we plan to go
on tour and go on the road as
soon as possible and you know the
situation will be
better by now and better by then excuse
me so we'll be able to enjoy meeting our
fans
just as much as our friends will enjoy
meeting us again